ja ja ja ja ja oh mein gott hallo mein
name ist luca und ich wollte heute
algerien spielen und jeder kennt ja
diese website wenn man darauf geht lahm
angeht doch vario punkt
[Musik]
es scheint so als wäre die website
tatsächlich gerade down tatsache freunde
da oben steht addario hier steht dass es
geht und da steht auch das ist aber das
geht einfach nicht
nun spielen wir heute wo man ein paar
andere sachen die so sind wie algari
wahrscheinlich gerade zeigen dass er
gabriel so ganz normaler cabrio gibt es
ja und wir schauen uns das heute mal an
was ist so für fakes von dem spiel gibt
diese spiele heißt addario punkt bz da
müssen wir nicht eingehen ich nehme
einfach gaga gestapelt das spiel hätte
ich es ruckelt wie sah ihr seht ja meine
maus ich gehe nach unten ich gehe jetzt
wieder nach oben ich gehe jetzt wieder
nach unten ruckelt einfach wie soll man
kommt eigentlich überhaupt nicht
geschmeidig voran und das liegt nicht an
mir und meinem internet sondern
tatsächlich einfach wohl am server man
hat oben links eine minimap wo man sehen
kann wo man sich befindet
roth also in einer gewissen form ist es
cool weil man wenn man mit freunden kann
man sagen ja ich bin der fünf- oder
irgendwie so aber das ist doch schiiten
wenn sie doch ganz genau wo man lang
muss damit man nicht nach außen driftet
und außerdem brauchen irgendwie noch die
anderen leute kriegt das ist doch ach du
heiliger ich gehe mal auf alex draußen
versuche ja man ja man ja ja ja ja ja oh
mein gott
ach komm du kleine page die ich fress
natürlich auch noch ach du heilige
scheiße da kommt aber zum glücksspiel
nicht dass normaler garrido sondern
können oben links sehen dass wir nur
noch hoch müssen und dann sind wir quasi
schon weg und ich fühle mich so als
würde ich ihnen gerade ist es möglich
dass ich meine teile mal irgendwann
wieder zusammen saugen irgendwie
passiert hier grad nicht so heiligen 1 1
[Musik]
wenigstens haben wir immer noch einen
kleinen teil von uns nicht und meine
kleinen baby sei ja du heilige
das war gar iovine man dass kassel war
wir waren tatsächlich direkt auf der 9
das war einfach nur cool ich habe mich
gefühlt als wäre ich gut hier haben wir
agrarökonomie das sind private server da
gehe ich einfach mal als joker ran und
kann dann hier auf private servern
spielen das sieht aber trotzdem sehr
öffentlich aus apropos was haltet ihr
davon wenn ich rein theoretisch mal ich
habe ja letztens angekündigt dass ich
übelst bock hätte auf youtube live
streams auf youtube.com schrägstrich
kontrakte schrägstrich leib das ist
meine livestream seite da werdet ihr
derzeit noch nicht sehen und
wahrscheinlich denke ich auch erst mal
wieder sagt er uns das wenn er überhaupt
nicht live ist das frage ich mich
ehrlich gesagt gerade auch ich habe aber
bock drauf man einfach dann so ein
leitgeb zu machen und dann bei twitter
beispielsweise zu posten hey tag
freundlich auf die grad in crivitz
server addario kommt doch einfach mal
drauf und wir zocken runde zusammen fakt
ist game was haltet ihr davon weil ich
sage mir schon die ganze zeit ich liebe
addario ich liebe dieses spiel wirklich
über alles ich bin einfach nur richtig
gut darin und ich sage mir wirklich
immer ich hätte mega bock drauf babys
und private server zu machen dass ich
mit euch dann einfach zusammen liegen
die zocken kann und wie können dann alle
sagt man einfach mal was ihr davon
haltet dario pw hier steht sehr sehr
viel und ich glaube connecting
funktioniert nicht so ganz f you cannot
connect service check geht es immer noch
nicht auf dieser seite können wir auch
addario spiel und zwar browsergames.de
da können wir hier einfach mal zocken
und dann halt dein maul gari oakley
puncto wir zocken das ganze mal auf sap
global player und schafft eine kürzere
zeit zu überleben ich war verdammt noch
mal eine sekunde drehen und bin
gestorben
herzlich willkommen auf einem kanal
wir versuchen das ganze natürlich normal
spielen wieder
und werden hoffentlich diesmal irgendwie
ein bisschen länger überleben ich denke
der ist ein zweiter großer bruder
wir haben diesmal unten sogar auch noch
eine minimap schaut euch das an da wir
können wieder genau sehen wo wir sind da
unten gibt es einen chat dicker youtube
channel
dann schauen wir uns heute noch die
website die kann wieder nicht korrekten
diese webseite ist klar klar klar karla
cario okay ich war downloaded ich gerade
in what happened sowohl ich muss ctrl +
r drücken und dann kann ich irgendwie
das hat mir das gebracht hier ist
diesmal sogar die linie richtig krass
markiert dies nicht zu übersehen also
das jetzt wirklich bisher das spiel wo
ich sage da kann nicht flüssig rumfahren
alles läuft gut ich bin ort dem geist
gedenkminute
aber es läuft zumindest flüssig und ich
habe keine probleme damit dass irgendwas
hier total am lecken ist okay eventuell
habe ich gerade ein klitzekleines
problem erzeugt das war es vielleicht
richtig die klügste entscheidung gerade
alles klar freunde wir sind wieder up to
the bottom vom band skyline
tschüss